questo nuovo video sono migliaia sono
successo con 31 reti niente io caro la
mattina che cazzo ne siamo slack torbidi
lungo dell'episodio bella opera o
presunte cosa dove quando cosa è
successo no non sono via via via via via
via via via via via via via via vieni
con me tu sei bello di avvio via via
vianna veloce però sì l'ho messo sull i
sali [ __ ] veloce brace siete belli
siete molto belli molto molto ragazzi
che cosa cazzo è successo è bene così
essa è stata una bella esperienza molto
bella
giuro c'è veramente complimenti possiamo
uscire porterà da qualche parte di
decente questo ascensore non lo so visto
che sale
mi rifiuto di vedere che cazzo era mi
rifiuto è stato bruttissimo ma veramente
orribile siamo tornati qua bel
importante è tornare in posti si si si
si si hai una bella voce sensuale ma
giuro che ti prendo a schiaffi ragazzi
allora mi dovete spiegare il senso
tra queste tende che ci sono è il posto
dove lo più in questa mezza aperta
perfetto ecco posso entrare minchia meno
male che è illuminato almeno questo
grazie a dio
posso chiedere anche la porta e mi sento
più tranquillo c'è su una tazza di caffè
tranquilli tranquilli proprio calmi che
non voglio non voglio rotture di palle
per tutto il tempo c'è la prima questa
forza ok scorta bell'uomo a sei
veramente egocentrico metati su tutti
cazzo di muri ma chi è è un figo
se tu che vi parli nelle orecchie che mi
dai fastidio e l'omino michelin che
cazzo cimino michelin
beh questo non l'ho capito non è
esattamente l'omino michelin non è per
niente l'omino michelin io torno
indietro grazie io torni indietro bene
bene bene bene
sparito che cazzo succedere no non è
tornato ascolta ma che cazzo fai dei
problemi se non so se hai dei problemi
ma non mi guarda e lo supero noi che
misura lo sapevo che mi sfruttavano
tizia che ha visto però mi sto misto
prato misto frate bravi bravi bravi a
prefetto non mi hanno preso che culo di
abbia via via devo evitar libero simpson
chiasso mi sono salvato per miracolo
meno male che nessuno dei due è venuta
la mia parte di qua o vado a caso
ragazzi tanto non sto capendo più niente
quindi tanto vale è che cazzo però devo
schivarlo preghiamo che ma quanto sei
bello tra l'altro prego che passi avanti
e non giri a destra perché potrebbe
essere un problema così lo stai dando a
me posso prenderlo grazie preso una
pistola
questo me ne faccio di una pistola
dintorni c'è un ascensore che comparsa
dal nulla ti ringrazio sei molto genti
sei anche molto sexy e stato un piacere
conoscerti
se ti interessa io vado al piano
rispetto che devo scegliere
[Musica]
andiamo al 4 che mi sembra perfetto
tornati qui
complimenti per l'ambientazione
veramente ne vado pazzo mi fai aprire
questa porta senza spaventi o cose per
favore
ma scusate un attimo ragazzi c'è è una
specie di macchinetta del caffè questa
sì ma tu non mi devi dire che cosa devo
fare per i tg ottene intera stacco tale
infilo ho capito cazzo non c'è bisogno
meno ripeti che non sono deficiente è
finito rifarmi salleh vico a grazie ma
il caffè la benzina e volevo il caffè
questo problemi questi che cosa cazzo
sta succedendo perché dove siamo
chi è che piange ragazze non piangete
non piangete che fa vj e qui per noi non
piangete grazie
se dovevo dire questa cosa brutta va
bene sentite
non so dove sto andando di preciso ma
sto continuando a camminare da un'ora e
mezza mentre un [ __ ] continua a
dirmi delle cose attraverso un
altoparlante c'è ditemi voi se normale
questa cosa avrà una fine spero vi prego
scassato la luce benissimo non possono
anche passare sotto le luci che si
scansano perfetto dai è buono a sapersi
ferdinando da molto tempo che non ci
vediamo no no no no no però non hai
capito di stare fermati più volte in
faccia chiudi insomma donna quanto melo
pupa fermina quantomeno pupi quantomeno
pubblico a dove di questo vedi non lo
vedi perché c'è la porta è stronzo di
merda posso passare adesso ne sei andato
[ __ ] [ __ ] chiudiamo questa kg die
attraverso le porte non ci passa almeno
questo scatta ferdi facevano un patto un
parto i do un euro e tutti togli dal
caso che un euro 1 ecco che corrompendo
la gente funziona bene non c'è più
perfetto grazie ferdi va bè ragazzi io
d'ora in poi quando fin quando gioca gli
horror mi preparo il pacchettino di
monete ho detto che ti do l'euro ha
detto allora sei stronzo secolo stronzo
nell'anima e in parte un patto e non è
che puoi fare cazzo che vuoi questa no
no che non vedo un cazzo ed è che mi
vien da vomitare almeno quello più dopo
chiude e portati via volta chiude la
porta chiudi con quanto difficile chiude
una porta ma [ __ ] non chiedetemi
dove sono non ho idea però c'è quel
[ __ ] che mi sta seguendo quindi devo
evitare di fermarmi per troppo tempo ci
sono già passato di qua no dai è di
nuovo nel loop c'è di nuovo a caso
finché una scacchiera
io ce la reggina c'è la reggina la
reggina l'ho presa per tipo un'ora fa ok
ma cannes tipo 26 pezzi ma va bene tanto
hanno vista io è vero ma io posso
sparare a ferdinando più visto e ciò
adesso posso andare anche nel western
fare il cazzone no ma sei serio o 26
pistola e non posso ammazzare quelli
invertebrato spiegatemi sta cosa che non
ho capito in forza forza via di cui via
via vigna non voglio vedere in via di
qua di voci ma ancora
ma come a parte per drogarvi sembrava
qualcosa aste piante perché non si può
uscire che non c'è un'uscita vera e
propria c'è solo quel pezzo hamas e
casso lucida vedute di parate prima o
poi mi chiama che posso io si scassa
tutto sono di nuovo all'inizio ma siete
seri si sa cosa sono cascato in un buco
in lungo probabilmente ci caga wafer di
là dentro come voglio delle spiegazioni
quali problemi al cervello avete a chi
sta succedendo veramente ragazzi non ha
senso c'è non è possibile che sono
caduto da un chilometro in un buco
ancora al tavolo trovato il pedone
perfetto dove litro nella scacchiera e
poi e metto anche il pedona beh ma mi
spiegate il senso di queste cose
ecco questo senso r e patta carta
papapapapapapapapapappappa bahram
paparazzi a chi è che il mora che sbatte
le porte così che sento facciamoci un
esame di coscienza tutti quanti mitiche
che fa sto casino da mezz'ora che non è
possibile dove dovrebbe fare la
scacchiera di prima non mi ha visto non
è visto mi ha visto mi hai visto mai
visto mai visto mai visto apriti e non
si apre un cazzo e sto gioco non si apre
un cazzo però mio dio dove vado dove
dove lo schiera sì non è se chiudi
chiudi chiudi chiudi che c'è quel tizio
nudo che gira anzi in pantaloni era
meglio nudo che quei pantaloni fa schifo
cosa mi manca allora mi manca un cavallo
il re è una torre ma vaffan dove dove li
trovo a tutti sti pezzi tutta colpa di
sti luridi chi è cchiù di clienti
è una canzone che conosco io
ragazzi ma perché devo finire allora
possono anche carmi sopra è uscire no
perché non è ma ok non è neanche tanto
bagato sto gioco seriamente devo giocare
una roba del genere no basta dai bassa
bassa vi prego sono penalizzato vi
supplico ritrovi pezzi perché c'è gente
che mi segue la batteria
io ti ringrazio dai che ci arriviamo da
qualche parte dai non so neanche dove
sto andando ma da qualche parte stiamo
andando quindi importante arrivare no no
no no però se passo piano se passo piano
non mi vede non mi vede mi avvilisco ma
quanto poi essere brutto no anche quelli
in giacca e cravatta no è che cazzo
troppo troppa gente troppo zelo tradotto
pezzo è sparito sia nell'acqua non vuole
dell'acqua non volevo in bicchiere
d'acqua siano è sparita perché se
l'annuncio più questo problema per
apprezzare quando dedico le persone che
non so o hanno sete o vanno a fuoco che
hanno bisogno d'acqua ecco non sai mai
che cosa offrirgli
ma quanto scudetti bene fratello
[Musica]
no vabbè sei serio di serio ma torna è
tornati indietro è tornati indietro si
chiude si chiude questa roba si chiude
si chiude si chiude ma quantomeno tutto
quanto meno pupa quantomeno è passato
[Musica]
vide uno sforzo in più che io posso fare
in questo momento non mi sono ridotto
non so perché ma proponendo sky ogni di
standing